[Musica]
si spegne e sta merda a che vi lascio
paranoia ragazzi ci vediamo dopo ce vò
poi sperate di no la smetto è una roba
da urli e la madonna che fax è la mia
faccia perché perché i capelli nel fax
che strano
e molto strano e quel mostro ieri adesso
te lo ricordi lolitas transam ok notte
te lo ricordi
brava ma brava ricordatelo adesso che no
a te no prima era un sogno e testa di
minchia e lui ancora mouans fioriti
divori devo correre ma accordi come se
fosse l'ultima cosa che fai perché santi
che uccidono neanche prima sapevo dove
nascondano i figurati se lo sono de ski
che fa questo rumore quando mi colpisce
non l'ho capito fruga ce l'ho fatta
adesso mi in cura tanto lo so rega che
dovevo nascondermi nel camino cazzo
evocato shenron che è successo l'ho
fatta lega ce l'ho fatta perché non mi è
ancora inglobato ho vinto e chi sei
addormentata e ti sei dimenticato a casa
e successo scommettono che vuoi mi sono
addormentata muova ma non l'avrei mai
detto per caso ti ricordi che chiari in
seguito uno zombie per mangiarti le
budella lo so che ti chiedo niente
colazione colazione la mattina ma che
cazzo sono sicura che non era un sogno
ma davvero
e allora che cosa cazzo ci fai ancora
qua dentro nera un cane randagio
sembrava umano nuove e sembra una specie
di zombie ok ma veramente madre non mi
crederebbe mai e lei non mi lascerebbe
restare a casa e c'era già nel cast
sentirà gli schiaffi c ancora più
ragiona tornerà questa notte ma non lo
scopriremo perché ce ne andremo via
dovremo fare un rifugio ma dopo io
l'ammazzo l'ammazza l'ammazzo aspettare
finché se ne va a notti devi levare tu
dai [ __ ] perché sei stupido
la fabbrica è impossibile trovare le
porte che narrativa che bello c'è
qualcosa nel retro ma come prova a
vestirlo ma è vuoto ma chi cazzo dicendo
devo provare a rivestire mi coi vestiti
psicosi ancora a preti blue e pink marca
in kind of ga'hoole in preferenze è una
chiave una [ __ ] chiave ma vaffan
corini qualsiasi cosa dovrà succedere
succederà ma veloce è quella questa
perfetta c'è un piano ragazzi io non so
che cosa succederà in questa stanza ma
se si presenta qualcuno non
preoccupatevi o un piano michele dopo
questa mi devo prendere randellate da
solo è gallop oyeah a un titani to play
this audio pensava deciso music
understand perfetta maianti ios to play
o di san gold crime quindi mia zia
suonerò questa canzone tutto il tempo
allora suona quello che vuoi da na na na
como va skrillex reticolo non è
esattamente
a me non ha tolto sto cazzo all'orologio
di sta mandando fuori di testa
[Musica]
il suono è strano no è che non è scrive
ho sentito un suono metallico
sarà mica una chiave nascosta nel piano
c'è qualcosa ha nascosto nel piano una
chiave ma vero non ci posso credere
ragazzi c'era una chiave nel piano ma
guarda te che incredibile
senti vicino li sto cazzo è mi dovresti
proteggere tour e gay vi sarà il po in
campanello mi stai sicuro hai capito
mi stai succo è che problema assai al
cervello mi amico mi ha mandato delle
pere sono troppe per per mangiarle da
soli questo è un doppio senso regalata
vorrebbe mangiarmi le pere ma non può
farlo
mi piacciono molto le pere noa che piace
il cetriolo zia 6 bene miss miss
takamura mi sembri molto saggio se ciò
le major match ho le mie cose euro pre
cazzo non ci crederà mai se li dirò del
mostro non ha di che c'è le tue cose c'è
il ciclo a non ho dormito molto e
implica che sono incazzata di tutto
quello che posso dire è stai tranquillo
ok ma potresti essere affaticata quindi
prova a rilassarti sim allevati dai
cazzo bene scusami bravo zio abraham e
non capisce quando gli dico se cosa meno
ma devo preparare la cena e poi possa
andare a dormire prepara per due giacche
sai che ti vengono a trovare grazie
dell'ambulanza
grazie grazie a dovrei stare sveglia
stanotte ma guarda giorno 3 non hai
dormito ma serial a dormitorio no vabbè
se il mio idolo
sono così stanca ma non posso
addormentarmi e tipo freddy krueger
camminare in giro per stare sveglia
vincere che la cosa peggiore che potesse
fare le propre visco dormire
c'è il piano che sta suonando da sola
suonando per la canzone esattamente
quella di mia zia salva su cazzo si è
che stava solo piano suoni da solo piano
ci hai un piano ho sentito il piano si
l'ho sentito anch'io può essersi suonato
da solo no sarai tu che sei stanco poi
sarà che si urli sexy saranno mica dei
capelli
non posso muovermi qualcosa che mi ha
preso la gamba e sotto il piano non
dirvi che non scelga vorrei che ci fosse
taylor swift in certi momenti ma
qualcosa mi ha preso la gamba finiremo
notizia madonna quanto sei bello se il
tuo amico mio e dirlo cazzo che sognavo
insieme facciamo un featuring nicki è un
fa vj featuring the zombie no no sta
lontano star onta veri che non dormire
non sono un cazzo si serve un cazzo devi
dormire che doveva da nascondere questo
nel cesso in eccesso la toilette puzza
porca [ __ ] dove posso nascondermi mai
adesso ma perché [ __ ] che cosa
cazzo ti corri così cosa ho fatto
petric enrique tutto ho fatto un
disastro anto muoio perché ci sono
20mila arma ii e ovviamente avrò beccato
quello che mi è giusto cioè se ogni
tanto ci vuole a botta di culo con la
potente proprio la mattina mi sono
addormentata in che la diversità di
questo gioco e basta brava non posso più
sopportare tutto questo
brava cazzo se il suo minuti e tre notti
3 quel coso che ho sentito sulla mia
gamba
che schifo devo chiamare mamma e tornare
a casa non posso rimanere in questo
posto ma dai ma a verona ragazzi è un
genio sta tizia diavoli un premier
chiama tua madre emma porta la pizza per
due la miche
ma è così presto più cosa certo stare a
casa un pochettino ma di che cosa stai
parlando
e successo qualcosa ci sono stati un po
di problemi devo tornare indietro per
favore è troppo tardi perché ma che
stronza
ma come non so che cosa è successo ma no
cara mamma [ __ ]
mamiya quella è la tua casa adesso
minchia mia madre io chiamassi mia madre
gli dicessi mamma visto sbucciato
ginocchio mica chiama i pompieri non
chiamarmi per queste cagate di mattina
[ __ ]
macché madre stronzo ma ma proprio la
vita scappa la sua non c'è bisogno della
mammina perché appare ovviamente non lo
farà mai però ci ha provato lega almeno
c'è il vicino di casa che vuole solo
inglobarli però i meno esigenti le ha
non era e non è aperta questa l'offerta
a cazzo ok a caso proprio c'è un
coniglio il coniglio si va beh magari in
crociera che poi mi dalle colpe qui io
non ho toccato niente non rompete le
balle
la bambola è caduta e si è rotta ma dai
non ho sentito tra mica una chiave
dentro non c'è la chiave ma dai
veramente stranissima questa la luce
spegniamo le luci la lucha posto
spegnere on and on
madonna mi sta incalzando 8 o kay prof
quindi adesso è accesa sotto la lampada
da capra kampala per una chiave all'aver
non avevo dubbi tra una chiave sotto la
lampada sotto la lampada ragazzi ci sono
le chiavi ricordate la chiave campo è
una roba che ormai gli chiave è tanto
mancando porte west è quella di sotto
quindi non è che c'è un lecco che e
molto piu figo del mio perfetto ho
trovato un pezzo di carta quindi gates
login travis di ed il terzo guys in
crisi quando ti addentri nel profondo
degli abissi gli abissi sia dentro
dentro di test c'è lo tsunami potrebbe
essere è il ricorso del del pop che
merda di giardino ogni volta una persona
stupida sicuro che è sicuro è qualcosa
sta luccicando all'interno perfetto sarà
una chiave secondo me è la tua zia che è
morta riesch inside devo raggiungere
buttarmi nel è molto lontano eh vabbé
tira sulla corda che urlo fatto sarà
mica uscito lo zoom a non son caduto ma
coperto il caduto di sotto casa ma non
sei morta non posso salire da qua
perfetto cioè nel culo e la censura
qualcuno qualcuno attenti a non so cosa
può fare alleviamo ci dai cazzo prima
cosa è stata una roccia muro sembra
molto brittle non solo dire brittle ma
non importa se ok sdrucciolevole così
posso fare una crepa va bene ci proviamo
ragazzi voglio andare a dormire ho paura
brava zia e sfondato il muro cos'è
questo non lo so se ci sono degli spazi
nascosti nel pozzo già strano che ci sia
un pozzo in casa
mortacci sua vita cadendo addosso attimo
a camminare fa cazzo vuoi finché non
abbiamo in superficie arriviamoci
cortesemente in orario decente perché in
questo caso è dio santo la voce e anche
qui devo correre corri carica buttare
vabbè ormai è cosa ormai siamo
condannati corri fai quello che vuoi
sono alex uars era campionessa olimpica
di marco quando non mi alleno io qui
sotto i pozzi assieme a mio fratello ci
stiamo a fare qui insomma che corriamo
come questo caso era su quei tacchi
lurida e nera un giorno giusto per
mettere il tacco 14 tra ancora ma basta
oddio cos'è il capo palestra e coste
facce e coste facce un vicolo cieco
perfetto buttati ancora ma clown 12 ore
sono qui ma vaffan
no sono svenuto d'accordo ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto è stato
allora sta diventando sempre più strano
questo che questa roba
spero che mi sia piaciuto il prossimo
episodio sarà l'ultimo grazie a dio non
ne potevo più di sistemi ceri chiavi non
so se si è capito e quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto come solito lasciato
momento vi piace per ogni mi piace che
mettete
cadrete in un pozzo in meno perché
capita di cadere nei pozzi quindi fa
sempre comodo anche alla pagina di
facebook e come la divide a trattenere
tiziana sul serio i siti 16 vediamo il
prossimo video meglio
[Musica]
porca lato i maroni
beh ragazzi io